how hard is it to simulate
all of the things that we've been
talking about each of the things we've
been talking about
and maybe one day all of the things
we've been talking about and beyond
meaning like from the initial
primordial solar system you know a bunch
of disks with
i don't know billions trillions of
objects in them like simulate that
such that you eventually get a jupiter
and a saturn
and then eventually you get the jupiter
and the saturn they clear out a disc
change the gravitational landscape then
earth pops up
like that whole thing and then be able
to do that
for every other system
in the uh every other star in the galaxy
and then
be able to do that for other galaxies as
well
um yeah so look maybe start from the
smallest simulation
like what is actually being done today i
mean even the smallest simulation is
probably super super difficult even just
like one object
in the kuiper belt is probably super
difficult to simulate i mean
i think it's super easy i mean like it's
it's just not that hard
um but um you know let's
let's ask the most kind of basic problem
okay so
the problem of having a star and
something in orbit of it that you don't
need a simulation for like you can just
write that down on a piece of paper
this gravity would like yeah i guess i
guess it's important to try to
uh you know one way to simulate objects
in our solar system is to build the
universe from scratch okay
we'll get to building the universe from
scratch in a sec um but let me just kind
of go through the hierarchy of
what you know what we do two objects two
objects
analytically solvable like we can figure
it out very easily
if you just you don't i don't think you
yeah you don't need to know calculus
it helps to know calculus but you don't
necessarily need to know calculus
three objects that are gravitationally
interacting
the solution is chaotic doesn't matter
how many simulations you do
you the answer loses meaning after um
after some time i feel like that is a
metaphor for dating as well but go on
now yeah so so
the fact that you go from analytically
solvable to
unpredictable you know when you are
when your simulation goes from two up
bodies to three bodies
should immediately tell you that the
exercise
of trying to engineer a calculation
where you form this whole
entire solar system from scratch and
hope to have some predictive answer
is is a futile one right we will never
uh succeed at such a simulation like
excited just to clarify you mean like
explicitly having
a clear equation that generalizes
the the whole process enough to be able
to make a prediction
or do you mean actually like literally
simulating the objects as a hopeless
pursuit
once it increases beyond three the
simulating them is not a hopeless
pursuit but the
outcome becomes a statistical one
what's actually quite interesting is i
think we have
all the equations uh figured out
right like you know in order to really
understand this
the formation of the the solar system is
suffices to know
gravity and magneto hydrodynamics i mean
like the combination of uh maxwell's
equations and
you know nivea stokes equations for the
fluids you need to know quantum
mechanics to understand
opacities and and so on but we have
those equations in hand it's not that we
don't
have that understanding it's that
putting it all together
is a very very difficult and b if you
were to
run the same evolution twice
changing you know the initial conditions
by
some infinitesimal amount some you know
minor change in your calculation to
start with you would get the
you'd get a different answer this is
one this is part of the reason why
planetary systems are so diverse
you don't have like a you know very
predictive path
for you start with a disk of this mass
and
it's around the star therefore you're
going to form the solar system
right you start with this and therefore
you will conform this huge
outcome a huge set of outcomes and some
percentage of it
will resemble the solar system
you